[Music]
so we're here with Marco Francisco [ __ ]
where I said I won't about to have a
nice interview with our brother know how
you been fine thank you
come do not we're gonna be discussing
some of the chapters and things that you
discussed in your book very interesting
a lot of good information that's there
that we'll be discussing here keep
tuning in it's funny you haven't read
this book you know but the book begins
with words exactly here he says I'm a
warrior you had talked about with your
family some of the hardships like back
and other people can relate like to have
a I have a friend
god I'm who accept Islam and then he
went back to his area and then I started
really giving him problems you found a
deep depression you had some similar
situations with that and how do you
handle that it's not easy you know
you're human and of course that it's
hurts you know especially if someone is
more close to you it hurts you more yeah
but you just have to you know forgive
them understand their lack of knowledge
their influence you know they have
prejudices and you have to see all these
your hardships there's a kind of a test
of your faith
do you see the irony here is like every
everything that people are pointing
towards Muslims like being intolerant
being Barbara cause it's like they're
the one but they don't see it is that
crazy imply like mind you know blindness
and using me or something and
automatically they're putting me in this
you know kind of box you know they have
prepared yeah
in the conscience in the mind they put
me in this you know box and there's no
question about it so that's like media
do you think that's they're victims of
the mass medium annihilation right so
now they've taken their information from
he said she said you know third party
sources and all these pictures you know
all this your everyday repeated repeated
horrible pictures horror scenes and you
know it's a this everyday shocking you
know shocking pictures of shocking
stories yeah and they have build up this
this these beliefs which are totally
wrong yeah they are convinced that they
are right yeah but the only thing you're
trying to do is you're trying to humbly
sincerely worship your Creator alone the
one God you're trying to be a good human
being you're not trying to harm anybody
yeah I mean because that's you know I
have good manners good character yeah
and the people are scared you know
they're put in a state of fear yeah and
then you are put in a state of fear your
reasoning will not function normally
yeah and they don't understand yes
they're so afraid you know you're Muslim
oh maybe you'd blow up just go in front
of us spontaneously you know it's
comical in in a way but this is how it's
it's nonsensical it's like in a way like
you said it's comical it's you know it's
beautiful how you know when when you
really open your mind and your heart and
it seems like sometimes just to get to
that stage people are so blocked and
reserved but that's why it's so
important obviously that we show to our
good manners and
and our character because the problem
Hamid peace and blessings be upon him he
said I have not been sent except to
perfect good a lot good manners right so
what do you think there you know
sometimes even you have all this
information but people you know until
they see some things in action right and
that my experiences in these cases there
is no point in going into the Bates no
point in trying to read with this reason
to unlock they the program they're like
hypnotized yeah my experience is only
through this good manners through
through the way of the heart yeah to
touch their hearts not to try to change
their minds because their minds are kind
of fixed you know cemented yeah but it's
better to try to go after their hearts
through kindness through some showing of
some you know nice things being
compassionate and patient right yeah
that's that's sometimes we get upset you
know a lot of us made that mistake
because it's so simple to understand
it's so simple it's LOM submission to
the creator not to creation doing good
deeds look the proof and evidence we're
not blindly following this you know it's
it's look at the evidence look at all
these things that if you look at it
you'll be here or or I'm also but
they're not thinking he reminds me of
that you know the story we have when
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him he was helping the elderly lady
with with her bags or merchandise
whatever it was and he was walking with
her and she was saying she was telling
him while they were walking you know the
story saying stay away from this man she
was Aslan during it she didn't know that
that was into the place' right here at
being so kind to her so nice to her and
she was so impressed by him and then at
the end after this long journey together
of him accompanying this elderly lady
helping her with her bags or whatever
else to get her to her destination
finally should let me give you somebody
stay away from this man and then she
asked who are you and she said i'm that
man
and if he from the beginning he didn't
do this way if he start to say no no you
are wrong I'm about me I'm the good one
she wouldn't yeah by true since think
he's a bad man but this way you know by
helping her being so good for her he
could reach her yes and change her mind
and later then she ended up accepting so
here's a beautiful story yeah
hamdulillah and this is the example for
us how to to behave not to not to go
into this too much this heart debates
you know even not to have all the
arguments when I said you need to be
came from not to humiliate the opponent
yes yes that's very important like or we
say leave room for the person because
now their ego gets right the way you and
they want to prove their right yeah but
I think I like like you did anyone who
sincerely comes into looking into the
evidence of Islam with an open heart
open mind and sincerely wanting to know
the truth it's so blatantly clear right
it doesn't take a rocket scientist or
PhD to figure this out it's a simple man
for other men and it doesn't have to
have a higher education to understand
basic principles no we're here at the
studio we just finished recording I'm
really great so we went with our guests
in Sutterville much love & salams to all
the brothers here at the studio doing a
fabulous job
Thank You brothers
yeah keep tuning in and look out for
this amazing episode we just did some
great information if you haven't
subscribed subscribe right now so when
it comes out and shall law you guys
would be getting it to you
you were saying Allah but what does that
mean for the people that never heard
this term alone why do you instinctively
say a lot harder because when we when we
see when we heard when we get know much
about something was we we never heard
met before this is like you know like
standard practice you know to say this
words
Allahu Akbar like supporting of this
kind of situation you you know this kind
of information like our our initial
initial book ibogaine ihe Allah yeah
naivety does mean that there is nothing
happening without his no knowledge
without without Allah it's insured